[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here a b c d e
f g h i j k l m n o we're like halfway
through the alphabet already google is
moving pretty fast so either way android
o developer preview is out now it's been
out for a little bit it's been announced
we have a logo we don't have a name it's
always a dessert theme i would guess
it's oreo but i'm always wrong so your
guess is as good as mine either way it
appears to be a pretty incremental
update so it's not this huge massive
overhaul you would have heard about it
already if it was but there are some new
stuff and we'll go over that but for the
most part it's a mostly behind the
scenes update stuff you might not even
notice if you weren't familiar with the
previous version of android but that
doesn't mean there isn't some cool stuff
to cover so this is your top five new
features of android o so number five is
your lock screen customization so this
actually lies in the system ui tuner
which is a new feature added with
android marshmallow and it's kind of
hidden like developer options but once
you unhide it it holds some pretty cool
stuff that i hope sticks around or even
graduates from the system ui tuner into
more visible main features so with lock
screen shortcut customization you know
how on your lock screen you have the
swipe up from the left to open your
voice control or swipe up from the right
to get to your camera this actually lets
you change those shortcuts to whatever
app you want so if you have some
favorite apps that you launch a lot more
often you can go through literally all
the apps on your phone and pick your
favorites and that will swipe up to
unlock into whatever app you choose so
that can be pretty useful if you text a
lot or tweet a lot or snapchat a lot
whatever you pick those shortcuts will
be on the bottom and i think that's
pretty neat now number four is what i
would call contextually aware
text selection dialogue it's a terrible
name but it's way cooler than it
actually sounds so you know how whenever
you select any text just plain text on
android you get a couple options to copy
or cut or paste or select all well now
the selector is actually context aware
so if you highlight an address a google
maps link will actually appear and you
can hop right into google maps just from
that selection so if you have someone
texting you a phone number you highlight
that phone number it gives you a link to
call that number immediately so that's
the kind of convenient stuff it's
recognizing i'm hoping it'll also work
when i highlight a link it'll be able to
open that up into my web browser but
usually that's just a hyperlink anyway
but either way pretty cool stuff i'm
happy to see now number three is a
little bit of customization with the
navigation buttons down at the bottom
we've seen this built into a couple
third-party skins but this is also in
system ui tuner so you can now choose
between a compact which puts them all in
the middle or a left leaning or right
leaning set of buttons so people with
big phones and small hands will find
that easier to reach from one side with
one-handed use and then you can also add
an extra button or two on the bottom
that stay permanently there so a
clipboard button is an example not sure
if it's for copy and paste functions or
just a permanent place to view your
clipboard because it's not fully
functional here yet but the president is
set and it's pretty cool i'd like to be
able to add my own button there whatever
i want now number two is a refreshed
notifications panel this is a subtle one
it's definitely a visual one and you'll
notice it if you've seen previous
versions of android the icons up top and
the quick settings are now a little bit
cleaner there's some new icons up there
too
the thin lines underneath some toggles
but also check out that slick new
animation for revealing from the icons
as you swipe notifications down that is
pretty hot and then you have a couple
new notification behaviors it seems like
these get a little bit more complex
every time
and that would be true but it's not too
crazy this time first of all the battery
percentage is revealed with one swipe
instead of two i really like that
because i like seeing my actual
percentage instead of just trying to
guess based on how full the bar is and
then you can do a half swipe over on a
notification to snooze notifications
from specific apps for some time so this
might low key be one of the most
underrated features so let's say you
just dropped a fired tweet your phone is
blowing up with all these twitter
notifications instead of muting your
whole phone you can snooze just your
twitter notifications for say 15 minutes
and that will still allow you to not
miss any calls or any emails or any
other notifications then when that's
done it'll come back i think that's
pretty awesome my only complaint here is
i wish the half swipe was a little bit
easier it's still way too easy to
accidentally do the full swipe and then
you just dismiss the notification
completely and you can't get that back i
did that a lot but i still really like
the ability to snooze notifications from
just a single app that is really cool to
see now the last one number one is a
whole new settings app and this one is
maybe the only actual big redesign in
the entire top five is the new settings
app is a lot cleaner it's visually
overhauled i think the old settings apps
and even on other phones besides the
pixel was starting to get a bit
overwhelming with the sidebar and the
tons of settings but now it's a lot
simpler looking and it's a much shorter
list and the side out menu is gone as
well overall it's a shorter top level
list but you can still dive more into
the actual settings or just use the
search bar just to get to stuff that you
know is there
it's black and white now as well and
also some of the pages like the storage
information readout look a lot cleaner
plus they give you that big important
visual up top that is pretty helpful
same thing with like the battery
settings for example it still breaks
down by your most used apps but you
still get that big clean graphic up top
for the percentage and estimated time
left and power management tools but yeah
that's it there you have it those are
the top five at least from what we know
right now best new features in android o
don't know the name yet like i said but
we'll be finding that out pretty soon
and it's a developer preview so this is
still evolving there will be new
versions of it and there will probably
be new features added in the next couple
months before it becomes official and
rolls out to phones like you don't get
these huge overhaul updates every couple
months or it will be a little bit crazy
and obviously still most phones don't
have the latest version of android
already yet so this will be rolling out
slowly
but from what we've seen what is your
favorite new feature let me know
thank you for watching talk to you guys
the next one
peace
[Music]